I read an article recently in InStyle magazine,
that made a light bulb go off.
Yes. I had an aha moment.
They put out an article
about the idea of a divorce registry,
where friends and family can come together
to help an individual replace items
around the house that they lost
in a divorce.
It's to celebrate a fresh start
the way we celebrate new beginnings, like a wedding.
And I'm just so excited to talk about this today
with an incredible mom of two.
Please welcome Lori Simonelli.
(audience applauding)
Hi.
Hi Lori.
How are you?
Well, I'm really good because a light bulb went off
and then our amazing producers found you
and you got divorced this year.
And I just want to ask you, how is it going?
How was it for you?
How is your new normal in the times of so many new normals?
Look, it wasn't easy.
I'm great right now, but you know,
we were married almost 17 years.
We were together 20.
So when something like this happens,
you kind of lose your identity.
But my ex's name is Nick
and we pulled out all the stops.
You know, we tried everything to not have a divorce.
We didn't want to do that.
We both believed in marriage.
We tried everything together.
As a couple, we realized
we can't put those pieces back together.
And so we, you know, we finally came to the realization
that we needed to kind of end this chapter.
Well, it's funny that you use that word chapter,
because life is this unwritten book.
And I've had to convince myself
of these things when I was like 13
and washed up and just a waste toy.
And I was like, I felt
like that chapter would be my narrative forever.
But you realize that the book keeps getting written
and you're actually the writer.
And this is a chapter.
Right.
Maybe the closing of one, the opening of the next.
I appreciate that you use that word.
I think it symbolizes a lot of things.
What has been a difficult aspect
about this that you didn't foresee?
You know, I think probably one of the hardest things
I saw was the first email that came through,
that said, "Simonelli versus Simonelli".
And I said, "What is this?"
Like we're Nick and Lori,
we're not Simonelli versus Simonelli.
So that was very difficult to process.
And then you had the moments where you are speaking
through attorneys, and it's just very impersonal.
But Nick and I always tried to kind of
like bring it back down.
And we talked throughout everything.
We lived in the same house throughout the whole divorce.
We ate dinner with our kids.
So, you know, that was hard with attorneys.
And one of the hardest things was sitting
down with the kids.
Yeah. And this article said, when someone gets divorced,
often their friends and social circles wanna show up.
But they are not quite sure how.
And a registry gave something concrete to point to.
And that was where the light bulb went off for me.
I thought, why is there not a registry?
Because inevitably in, I would say the majority
of divorces, things are divvied up.
Sometimes people have catastrophic losses.
But what did your friends do for you?
You know, I have a few very very close friends
and they were just there.
They were there to listen.
They just made me laugh.
Yeah.
You know, look, they knew that we had,
that Nick and I had a great relationship.
So there was never any bad feelings.
I mean, they're still friendly with Nick.
Right. Well, I think that you
and Nick have a very rare amicability
in this circumstance.
We do.
We're lucky.
Please do a Ted talk, Lori.
(Lori and the audience laugh)
I think it'll get a lot of hits.
And your friends, Julie, Melissa and Hillary,
they've been watching this whole time and they're here.
Hi ladies.
[Julie, Melissa and Hillary] Hi.
Oh my God!
There they are!
(audience applauding)
And we talked all about you
and we have a little surprise for you.
Please watch this.
Hi.
Thanks you guys so much.
It's really, really nice to meet you.
Thank you for doing this for Lori.
She is the most amazing person
and she would give the shirt off her back
to any of her friends.
I think there's only one silver lining
of any breakup and it's girlfriends.
I'm there for her whenever she needs me
to talk or laugh.
I just love her to death.
She's such a good person.
So every day on my way to work,
I would call her for like a half an hour chat
on the way in.
And you know, most days she would start off crying.
And at the end we were both laughing just because, you know
to remind her like her, life's not over.
It's, you know, a new beginning and think of it that way.
I know when Lori had gotten divorced
she was shocked.
When you're getting divorced, you're like,
"I'm crying, everything's cool."
But maybe it's not.
Yeah.
Why are we allowed to have a registry for weddings?
I thought a divorce registry.
It's amazing.
Why hasn't anybody done this so far?
I know. When I went through a divorce,
we just kind of went through the house, like,
"Okay, you take this, I'll take this. You take this."
So I know she's missing a lot of stuff.
And especially in her kitchen.
When I think of registries
I immediately go to kitchen staff.
Is there anything else she's missing
or lacking like bedding or pillows or soft items?
Lori is definitely like farmhouse kind of style.
(indistinct) Lori's, you know, kind of taste.
She loves peanut M&M's in like the prettiest bowl.
In a bowl?
Yeah.
I know like something that she absolutely has been saying
like a million times that she needs is, you know, a console.
Yeah. I have to say, I like both of these
and they're incredibly affordable.
I believe Lori wanted to be able to kind of DIY herself.
I thought this vacuum was super smart.
That will honestly be probably Lori's favorite thing.
Perfect. I think, we get through it with our friends.
So thank you guys so much
for doing this with me and letting me come into your circle.
Let's do this.
(audience applauding)
I just loved meeting your friends.
Hi ladies.
[Julie, Melissa and Hillary] Hi.
What do you think, Lori?
What are you thinking, feeling?
They're amazing.
I mean, Hillary, I've known forever.
I've known her since high school.
And she's amazing.
Julie, she's like the most unbelievable person.
And Melissa, Melissa is me times 10.
We always laugh about it.
My kids call her crazy Melissa.
She comes in my house and we laugh from
the moment she comes in till the moment she leaves
and my kids never come out of the rooms.
But when they hear her, they're like, "Melissa's here,"
and they run out.
This was so great to do this with you guys.
And we created this registry
and we purchased every single item on it.
So let's--
(audience applauding)
(lighthearted guitar music)
This is all for you, Lori.
And Melissa, Julie, Hillary and I,
just thought thoughtfully
about a few little goodies that'll get you going
and--
A few?
Yeah, exactly.
Oh my God!
Well, I have to tell you,
I don't think I would have had this idea.
If I wasn't working on this company
I just created with my partner, Shae Hong, called Beautiful,
which is all kitchen stuff.
I'm flabbergasted
and I can't believe these three are here.
It's like overwhelming.
Well, there is no clock that measures
when things evolve.
It's a mysterious clock that just takes time,
but our girlfriends get us through it.
So thank you, Julie, Melissa and Hillary and Lori.
(energetic music)